foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar
biomarkers and traumatic brain injury
and concussions finding novel biomarkers
I am antonina Salcido of lab roots and I
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by somalogic to learn more please visit
somalogic.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Dr
Jessica Gill Bloomberg distinguished
professor at John Hopkins School of
Nursing Dr Gill welcome you may now
begin your presentation
great thank you so much
um it's really exciting to be here today
and to be able to talk about some of our
research and
to really kind of give an overall
perspective about how biomarkers are now
and where we're wanting to go and so you
know we've really been looking at so
many different ways to find novel
biomarkers and so this is just an area
where there's so much growth and so much
potential so I'm hoping to get lots of
really great questions so please send
them in as it goes along
um the first thing that I want to talk
about and just present some of the
findings and this is really where we're
looking for novel biomarkers so I'm one
of the investigators at NCAA care
Consortium
um one of the really distinct values of
this is that it includes a high number
of universities as well as one of the
best things that we have in biomarkers
is to be able to collect a baseline
biomarker on an individual because we
know that that individual variability
really contributes to what we see after
concussion and so just to give an
overall idea about the design of this
study is that
um at these universities what and as
well as service Academy so we have eight
universities and two service academies
both the Air Force as well as West Point
um we are able to get neuropsychological
functioning balance as well as a blood
biomarker before they have any type of
Collegiate or training related
experience then
um during this time if they do have a
concussion or suspect to have a
concussion we can get blood on them as
well as their age gender team match
control and in the military service
um also with them if it's training
related or if it's
um if it's sports related and so this
allows us to look at individual
variability as well as to really do the
impact overall of timing one of the
other really great things about this
study and the design itself is that we
have individuals who are engaged in
sports and are active but are not at
risk for stopping passive hits as well
as brain injuries such as concussions
and so that allows us to look at the
impact of exercise and really minimize
that while also looking at the impact of
concussion focus is a great kind of lens
into identifying biomarkers that are
specific to concussion and in this
cohort we have used a number of
different things and represent just some
of them now
um all the findings I'm going to talk
about today are based on the
demographics that you can see there but
we've now gone on to do the rest of the
Care Consortium so The Chronic alcohol
is Cara 1.0 more recently we've
completed all of the biomarker findings
for the second phase but we're still
just in the process of analyzing so I'm
going to show you some of the findings
that we have and have published recently
me
sorry
nose Edge
um so one of the things that we found
um you know we looked at something
called fourplex and so that's g-fap and
you say it's on one those are the two
biomarkers that are identified by the
FDA as the diagnostic biomarkers of
concussion
but just to kind of bring it up now
um you know in this FDA finding it was
really identifying those individuals who
had a CT positive finding versus healthy
controls and so the nature of that is
really one type of neuroimaging finding
versus a healthy control and so in these
studies what we're doing is we're
looking at individuals that have a very
subtle injury so a concussion which
generally would not bring somebody into
an emergency room or to seek care these
are things that are witnessed or
observed by a trainer and thought to be
like wow we really should look at it but
it's not something that necessarily
um you know means that you're going to
get neuroimaging to have a neurosurgery
Neurosurgical intervention
and so it's really the more subtle
things that we see and so what we can
see overall is we kind of replicate
those first findings
um finding that gfap as well as usual
one are elevated in the acute period and
this acute period is anywhere between
two and 24 hours
um we also see overall that we get
elevations
um in that of Tau but we find that
there's a reduction at 24 hours later so
this is something as well as g-fap that
we've been looking at to really
understand the impact of exercise so I'm
going to show you some findings related
to that
[Music]
um we also are really interested in
biomarkers that are prognostic and that
they give us the ability to identify
that 10 of individuals who will go on to
have lasting symptoms or deficits after
a brain injury and that's really the
focus of a lot of our work because we
know that we need to diagnose TBI
because
um you know in a lot of settings we
don't have the ability to have
neuroimaging or in-depth phenotyping and
so having a biomarker that can say you
know this individual Had a Brain Injury
is really important and especially in
individuals who are in the military or
on Sports Fields because those are the
individuals we want to follow but really
the individuals that we want to follow
the most is not those that just had the
injury itself but those that are more
likely to go on to have lasting symptoms
and deficits and so we've done a lot of
work on return to play as well as return
to duty and so these are some of our
findings here the first initial finding
is that tau is elevated especially
um
acutely
so we see reductions overall
um and I'll give a little bit of insight
into that because what we found is it's
really related to a lot of physical
exercise
um and other factors but
um really understanding the impact of
that so we did that in the first study
which was in 2019
um we were able to expand this into the
NCAA care Consortium and find that we
were able to replicate Tau as being a
projector of return to play such that
the higher levels indicated that those
individuals were more likely to have a
prolonged recovery and that they'd have
more than 14 days in which they had to
be resting and not be able to come back
to play to be fully
um fully recovered
um one of the things about return apply
that's really important is that if an
individual does not have a full recovery
before they come back
they're about seven times more likely to
have another concussion and so that's
based on a lot of different factors such
as reactivity time and things that were
not really great at measuring right now
so having a biomarker that says you know
this individual is more likely to be
recovered and can go back to play and be
safe is really important because what we
know from our studies is that an if an
individual has a concussion and goes
back to play and then has a subsequent
concussion those are the individuals
that are most at risk overall and so
that's something that we really want to
use as a way to make things safer and
it's not just that we we want to
eliminate any sports that include
concussion because you know that's a lot
of the the identity
um I play Collegiate soccer and that's
something that was really really
important to me and so we don't want to
limit that but we want to make it safer
especially when we think about military
so we have individuals that need to have
training um related to many things like
firing a weapon
um being able to jump from a plane and
so that training often includes a high
risk of having a concussion and so what
we want to do is if you do have a
concussion we want to treat that the
best way we can and to minimize
secondary injuries and so what we're
seeing here
um is that Tau as well as gfap which are
in our secondary finding and more of a
trend which we're now following up on
was really important to look at related
to recovery
um and so that's some of the stuff that
we're looking at to see what predicts
recovery and how we can optimize the
care that we provide
we've also looked at phosphorylated Tau
and specifically what we've looked at is
181 as a specific isoform and the reason
that we look at this is Tau overall is
kind of an umbrella of a lot of
different isoforms that we want to
understand better because it's not just
tab elevations that are related to this
kind of recovery process but it's the
phosphorylation of Tau that we believe
is most important and once Tau becomes
hyper-phosphorylized it becomes
something what we call kind of like a
sticky protein that is hard for the
brain to clear and once there's
aggregation of that P Tau within the
brain it predicts long-term outcomes in
those individuals such that they may be
more likely to have something like
chronic traumatic encephalopathy or some
type of other cognitive decline and so a
lot of our studies both the NCAA
especially as we're going now into phase
two and now phase three where we're able
to follow these individuals over time
and right now what we're doing as we're
following individuals after they
graduate and as they go into kind of
their adult life to see how these
concussions actually impact overall
recovery but also their ability to have
a job
um relationships and things like that to
really understand the long-term overall
impact of these concussions on these
individuals
um and so this is really kind of a
Hallmark study to understand how these
injuries as well as repeated injuries
can relate to overall recovery but also
kind of a trajectory in life and so
that's where we're engaged now so
hopefully in the next couple years we'll
have some more findings related to this
but overall what we see is
phosphorylated Tau
um occurs especially within an acute
period
um zero to six hours and from Clinical
from pre-clinical studies we know that
there's a massive translation of this
such that phosphorylated Tau occurs
within a couple of minutes to hours and
so it's really important to know when
it's happening but then also when we can
also detect It in Blood and do that
sensitively
and so you know we've had a lot of
success looking at these candidate
biomarkers but again what we know about
g-fap and ucl1 is they're based on that
CT positive finding which is not often
observed in individuals who have more
subtle injuries like a concussion and to
give a little bit of a perspective when
we looked at studies within the care
Consortium we find that concussion very
rarely relates to a CT positive finding
less than one percent
and so we want to look for biomarkers
that are more based on the pathology
that we're seeing both in the subtle
injury as just the different nuances of
the type of injury and so what we've
done is try to find biomarkers that more
approximate this
um and the end goal of this is really if
we know what biomarkers are mapping onto
this it gives us an ability to identify
them and then use them to monitor those
individuals who've had a concussion but
even more important it gives us really
fundamental insights in the pathology
that relates to it so understanding
what's going on in these individuals is
essential as that we can then look and
see what interventions we can then
modify or use
um to intervene because what we see is
once individuals have the development of
symptoms especially in a chronic nature
after three months is that there's
neurological findings related to MRIs
that indicate that there's changes and
once those changes happen it's very
difficult to reverse and so if we can
identify those individuals early who are
more at risk for this and then to
intervene early
um we have a really great opportunity to
modify those risk factors so that those
individuals don't go on to have those
long-term symptoms
um but our current biomarkers of course
are limited
they're based on that CT positive
finding and so for our goal we're
thinking how can we expand this how can
we identify new biomarkers that give us
that identification that they've had a
concussion itself as well as an
identification of those individuals who
are more likely to have those lasting
symptoms and deficits and so this is why
we've used sumologic
um to do that and so
um instead of just looking at a
candidate approach as we would in Elisa
or something an antibody
um we can look at you know up to 7 000
proteins at the same time and that
allows us to look at different Pathways
not so not just a protein but things
that are up and down regulated and um
you know the down regular proteins are
really difficult to understand because
usually what we're looking for are
elevations and proteins that give us a
signal but this can give us kind of a
map of what's going on so we can
identify proteins that are both up and
down regulated but also have related
proteins that give us identification of
Pathways and so this opens up a whole
new Avenue so we're not just sitting
around a table and guessing that we
should look at this protein or that
protein
um based on some preclinical model or a
hypothesis that we can actually use the
data to kind of mold us and to guide us
to look at what's most important and so
this has been a law of the function of
my lab is to use these non
non-hypothesis approaches to identify
new biomarkers and then to really go
after them and understand their relation
to the brain injury and the overall
recovery process
[Music]
and so what we do is we look at
canonical Pathways
um so this is a way to see kind of where
the dysregulation is occurring and then
it's not just one protein but it's maybe
a set of proteins that we want to look
at and the value of this is we can
identify a dysregulated protein and a
pathway and then we can identify
interventions that will would then go in
to address that specific pathway and so
we use this in a way to be more
prognostic in that we want to understand
what's going on in those individuals
again both diagnostically as well as
prognostically
and so one of our findings so we did it
also within the care Consortium
um and so you know the whole idea is
that g-fap and uclan as well as normal
light chain they give us a lot of
ability to look at it but when we look
at the findings we only get area under
the curve of diagnostic accuracy of
about 0.8
um up to 0.2.3
um so what we see when we actually use
the Soma scan technology is that we
could identify new proteins again that
probably map onto that pathological or
the physiological changes that are
related to the concussion and so here we
have a finding um so these are proteins
that we wouldn't even look at so
um the first one is erythrocyte membrane
protein band 41 I would have never
looked at this so we call it epb41
um so we've seen up regulation of that
protein after concussion and so just to
give an idea so these are individuals
within 6 hours and 24 hours after a
concussion
and we look to see which proteins
specifically on the array and when we
use the array we are at 2500 proteins
um it's now been expanded to much more
but that's the platform we used about oh
God 18 months ago and so what we found
is it gave us a really really great
estimation by combining them but EPV 41
overall was great just having that one
but adding Alpha synuclein and so this
is a protein again that's down regulated
which we normally don't know how to deal
with this as much when we put it into
our models but we see that there's a
down regulation overall in Alpha's
nucleum we can when we combine epb41
with Alpha's nuclein we get a prediction
um that's almost 100 of diagnostic
ability in concussion and again just to
remind you that these are individuals
that have a concussion
um during a sport and so they're not
necessarily reporting to emergency rooms
and saying I've had a concussion but
these are things that are observed that
the individual might not even know that
they've had and so this is really the
most subtle form of concussion and so
you know going back to the FDA finding
um the combination of uchl1 and g-fat
did not get this performance and those
were individuals that had much more
severe types of injuries so it really
gives us an ability to look at specific
proteins that are up and down regulated
as well as the combination of those as
well as Networks
and just to kind of give a little bit so
this is some of our findings when we've
done these
um so seeing the CT positive finding we
do find that those same proteins are
elevated but in this study we added an
MRI subgroup and so these are
individuals that had both a CT and MRI
so CT is the standard of care but it
only really has that one diagnostic
profile with that that indicates that
you have to have neurosurgery to remove
that kind of blood clot or aggregation
of blood
but having an MRI finding opens a window
of pathology so it can be anything from
micro bleeds to break down the left
brain barrier things that really
um require a more sophisticated way to
look at it using this Advanced neural
Imaging and so it becomes again kind of
like Tau and umbrella of different
pathologies and so I'll present a little
bit more on that of one of the sub um
ones that we've been looking at more
um more intensely because it's really
important to understand the clearance of
proteins and so overall we replicate
that finding but again we extend it to
this group that has no CT positive
finding but it does have an MRI positive
finding and the significance of this is
that those individuals that have this
finding on MRI go on to have less
less ability to recover
but these are also individuals that
leave a standard emergency room and feel
like they haven't had a brain injury
because they had a CT positive negative
but these are the individuals that we
actually do want to follow because we
know that the recovery is compromised
and that we want to monitor them and
provide interventions
and so it kind of extends what we're
looking at it's just not this one
surgical intervention but all of these
different things that we can do for
these individuals that go and have
long-term symptoms and when we look at
those individuals again we have about
like a 15 to 18 percent rate of
individuals who have this mild brain
injury which is
um thought to be as a Glasgow Coma Scale
between 13 and 15. so these are
individuals who feel like maybe they
fell maybe they didn't somebody observed
them
um there might be substances related to
it so it's a really difficult group for
diagnosis when we see them in emergency
rooms and so this allows us to say okay
you have had a brain injury and you're
in the class of individuals that we want
to follow and it kind of makes it closer
where we can use precision-based
medicine to understand it and to really
improve the care that we provide because
if they are in that group of individuals
that subgroup of that 15 or so
um they can have long-term outcomes that
relate to compromise is in employment
relationships and overall health related
quality of life and so if we can
identify them and intervene early then
we have an option or an opportunity to
really improve their life and mitigate
the impacts of traumatic brain injury
and so one of the subtypes that we've
looked at is traumatic meningeal injury
and the reason that we see that this is
important first it's very difficult to
know to do neuroimaging in these
individuals in that it doesn't just
require an MRI which is not available
MRIs are only available in less than
three percent of emergency rooms so it's
not a standard care of intervention and
usually when an MRI is underdone it's
people coming in who say I've had a TBR
I was diagnosed with a TBI and now it's
been one month two months three months
and I'm having ongoing chronic symptoms
things like headaches sleep disturbance
mood disturbance but again that's when
we've already seen these neural Pathways
change and these changes we don't know
how necessarily to reverse and so we're
really kind of in a catch-up game when
we see them and so that's most of what
we know related to TBI and MRIs is this
more Subacute finding
um but within this study we have the
ability to look at traumatic meningeal
enhancement and that's done through the
contrast agent of gabolinium that is
given and so in this study what we see
um is the gadolinium gives a proxy of
the function of the blood-brain barrier
um and what's really important about
that is
we want to have a blood-brain barrier
that's intact in some ways
um so that if it's compromised what we
see is that there's infiltration of a
lot of immune cells and we get over
activation of the brain and we don't
want to have this chronic inflammatory
process and so what we know about
inflammation is that it's very essential
for recovery so in pre-clinical models
if you knock out inflammation altogether
you won't have recovery but if you knock
out the blood-brain barrier you can have
really detrimental effects completely
and so it's really the balance of
inflammatory activities that then
initiate neuropeptides that facilitate
both neural regeneration as well as
clearance of these proteins so we want
proteins like Tau as well as amyloid
beta to be able to get out of the brain
but we don't want so many immune cells
coming in that it disrupts the recovery
process and so it's really a balance of
severity as well as time and so if it's
very severe and the blubbering barrier
is not intact
um we can see infiltration of all these
different immune cells and over
activation of the immune system
if it ends up being prolonged
um then we can see overall chronic
inflammation which has specific deficits
that I'll show in a little bit
um and so it's really trying to
understand this and not just the impact
of inflammation but also this is really
important for clearance and so after our
brain injury we want to see degradation
of proteins that relate to recovery
um but if the blood-brain barrier is
intact and not letting those proteins go
out you can have aggregation and you can
have the onset of things like Tangles
and plops which we know is a con like a
Hallmark of CTE
um but we also want to have clearance
but we don't want to have infiltration
so it's really a balance of these
activities that's most important so this
has been a big function of our lab is
understanding how these proteins got
cleared both by the meninges
um as well as periovascular space which
is a proxy for lymphatic function and so
that's a series of studies I'd be happy
to talk about but um we don't have
findings now because it's a lot of the
work that we're doing
um so overall we can see this finding um
so this is here
um and you can see the the enhancement
of the meninges
um specifically after brain injury and
in this individual that we're showing
this brain injury
um and tme was was observed within 36
hours and then when we saw the
individual again at five days and so the
thing about team me also
is that you really only see it acutely
or subacutely within um 24 hours to
maybe a week after and so it's kind of
um a pathological finding that we're
starting to understand the mechanism
that relate to it but because it's a
very difficult procedure to have done
um and to get this data it's limited and
so what we're trying to do is find
biomarkers that approximate tme
um so we can use those in other studies
and we can identify mechanisms that
relate to this
um so that we can have a biomarker
because having these Imaging
um both is difficult if there's not an
MRI there and that's not going to become
standard of care anytime soon
um as well as to understand the nature
of it as well as how it relates to
clearance and the lasting nature of it
and so when we look at some of these
findings we see overall that we have
some indication that those individuals
who have that meningo injury have
elevation of those same biomarkers
um and so that gives us education but
again probably can we get better at this
probably because the biomarkers that we
looked at were in that four Plex that
were more related to tme uh sorry some
related to the um CT positive finding
and so by using more novel based
approaches we can actually identify tme
specific biomarkers
um and so this is a big project within
our lab as well as within within the
intramural program at NIH and nigs and
something that we're looking at because
what we see overall if individuals have
this tme finding
um acutely but more more importantly if
they have it and they continue to have
it at five to seven days later after the
injury those are the individuals that go
on to have long lasting cognitive um
declines and so we know that it's really
a prognostic indicator but it's not
going to be easy to measure using this
MRI method and so can we find a
biomarker that approximately it's in a
better way and then use it within
clinical error clinical care so that's
really the focus of a good amount of our
studies within our lab
the other Focus within our lab is how
can we use blog to get more specific
and so the error we've looked at is
using exosomes and so exosomes are Nano
vesicles that are secreted from every
cell in the body
um when it's secreted there's an
antibody that's put on the outside of it
that allows us to identify which cell
type that it came from and so we can use
that antibody to then say this is brain
specific or microglia specific or
astrocyte specific and so as we get more
and more evolved in this we can actually
say what's centrally related to the
brain because that's really what we're
trying to do in these studies especially
in mild
um TBI as well as concussion these are
not patients where we can get a CSF
level or we can do anything really in
depth and so we want a method that
allows us to get more close to the brain
without being intrusive in a clinical
nature and so this allows us to do so
and really the important part about
exosomes is when that exosome is
secreted from a cell it then goes to
bind to another cell so you have a brain
to brain connection specifically for
what we're looking at and the contents
of the exome are really important
because of a brain so if an exosome has
um more inflammatory dominated we can
see inflammation spreading from one
brain cell to the other this is
particularly important when we look at
microglia and so it gives us an ability
to kind of look into the window of
what's centrally related to understand
those mechanisms without getting very
invasive within a patient
um the other really important thing
within brain injury is this important
for clearance of these proteins so after
brain injury we see elevations of g-fab
Tau all of these different proteins as
well as amyloid if they stay within the
brain they can have
um translations of those proteins that
make it more kind of sticky so they're
going to stay there and when they stay
there they can they can compromise the
functioning of that neuron such that
that neuron is marked for degradation or
clearance um or death overall and so
what we see in TBI when we really see
deficits in a chronic nature is we have
black holes in the brain where there's
areas where neurons are no longer
connecting and that area of the brain is
no longer functioning and so what we
want to be able to do is say that this
is where that it's happening and we can
actually develop mechanism-based
interventions that allow us to go in and
be specific in the way that we're
intervening so right now what TBI and
concussions there's no medication
um that facilitates recovery overall
and so what we know is that the
pathology is very diverse so everybody
who has a brain injury has a different
type of brain injury and different
pathology and so using exosomes we can
actually get in there and see what's
going on and understand it in a better
way I'm going to show you a couple
examples of that
and so this is one of our findings so
um what we did is we did breacher so
breachers are individuals within the
military who have
thousands often of experiences of blast
exposure so blast exposure
um what we're coming to learn this is a
lot recently is that blast exposure is
not great for the brain
um so it's somewhat similar to what we
think about sub concussive hits or
something passive exposures and so these
are individuals who are training other
individuals to to fire something or to
dispose of a bomb and so there are
people going in and breaching
um some we call it like breaching a
barrier so they're coming in and they're
saying there's bomb boom I'm going to
come in and so they're exposed to high
numbers over their career and so part of
the military and the Department of
Defense was to come in and say you know
we've got a cohort of individuals who
are really compromised and concerned
about their health because these are
individuals that are highly functioning
um selected because of their
intellectual abilities but then over
time they're compromised or at least
they're reporting compromise
and so we did a series of studies at NIH
as well as continuing
to look at these individuals and
understand the nature of brain function
and really what's going on related to
this and so this is one of the findings
that we had
um so overall when we look at the blood
we see that there's really not that much
difference when we look at cytokines and
things like that and so just give kind
of a background
um anytime we have a study in
individuals who've had tbis or
depression or PTSD or have combat
exposure we see an elevation in
cytokines and those elevations really
overall to psychological as well as
neurological compromise and so when we
did this study we thought well this
doesn't seem like it this doesn't make
any sense because there are elevations
are not there and so what we did is say
okay the signal is not there in the
blood let's go more specific and use
these brain derived cytokine brain
derived exosomes to look at the contents
and specifically of cytokines and then
we also did some of the neuronal
biomarkers and so what we found is that
overall the inflammatory signal is not
there in the blood just the general
blood when we look at cytokines we
actually see them very elevated in brain
derived exosomes as well as elevations
and Tau and other biomarkers and so it
kind of gives us a window to say you
know this is something that we should be
worried about because overall neuronal
inflammation is one of the biggest
predictors of Alzheimer's disease and
other neurological compromises and so we
need to be able to really understand
that and so that motivated us to
undertake a study to look at
specifically the nature of brain
inflammation measured by a pet ligand
and so
that's not the one but
um so when we did that
um we were able to really like isolate
it so this led us to a different study
finding and I'm just going to give one
also idea about what we did so this
isn't a different cohort but we were
able to look at specifically lasting
neurological symptoms and micro RNA with
an exosomes that were brain specific and
so we see a specific pattern related to
this disc regulation so what you see are
dysregulated networks related to micro
RNA and so we see that this is a way to
really look at these chronic symptoms
and understand the nature of these
um this is really clinically important
because when we see veterans
um you know we have a number of
interventions we can do but they're not
necessarily pathologically based and so
how can we find these individuals and
really understand the pathology that
underlies the symptoms that we see
um there's also a lot of comorbidity in
these individuals so how can it kind of
indicate networks that are not just
related to brain injury but also PTSD
and depression as well as sleep
disturbance and so that's a lot of the
work that we do it's not going to be you
know this is the end-all medication for
treating TPI in a chronic nature but
this is what we see in clinical
populations and this is how we want our
intervene the best way
and so then it also led us to a study um
where we can look at Central
inflammation so this is this is really
exciting to me so
um we can use pet ligands so pet ligands
allow us to look at a specific pathway
um here we use tspo
um and this is James Stone's work at UVA
and so we were able to use this and to
look at brain related inflammation and
then we can see where in the brain it is
then we can do our um different
protocols to look at exosomes and make
it specific to see if inflammation is
there within those exosomes so again it
makes us more and more close to the
brain but this is the first window in
where we can get just a specific part
parts of the brain that allow us to
identify proteins that are dysregulated
as well as micro rnas and say like if we
really can change this we can change
brain function in these individuals that
have chronic symptoms and just give kind
of an idea about these types of patients
and so then once coming in and saying
you know I'm just compromised in my
sleep I can't work I'm having problems
with my relationships and so there are a
lot of vague type symptoms but if we can
get down to a pathology that we can
understand and intervene it gives us a
whole new window to really make an
improvement in their quality of life
and so kind of putting all this together
um you know our current limits when
we're looking at proteomics is
first of all sugar a slide or two on
this
um the time course of proteins is
important so what I always say it's not
just the right biomarker but it's the
right biomarker at the right time and so
there's very few studies that allow us
to collect multiple biomarkers on the
same person over time to really
understand the temporal relationship of
this and some of the other variables
that I'll talk about but this is really
what we need because you know when we
see people
um in combat after concussion as well as
in the emergency room they're coming at
highly variable times and so it's not
going to be one biomarker that's going
to say yeah you did or you didn't have a
TBI or concussion but it's really a
combination of the biomarkers and also
the understanding of time and how those
are changing
um we're also facing the technology of
how we can measure these very low
proteins
um especially in clinical settings so
you know we're looking at things like
you know grains of sand and olympic size
swimming pool how can we use this
sophisticated technology to understand
these small quantities that are leaking
out from the brain
um and that's always going to be one of
our complications of how we can really
get the best signal that we can
um both in blood as well as other
biological fluids
um another thing is mapping objective
fluid biomarkers on Imaging biomarkers
again
um what we want to do is be able to see
an Imaging biomarker and say okay now
we've got a fluid biomarker to
approximate this but because of all the
issues with individual variability as
well as timing this is not always
accurate so the pathology that's
occurring within the brain has a delayed
effect of what we see in the blood and
that relates a lot to the clearance
which we're trying to understand so we
can have a pathology within the brain
but we're not going to see that protein
unless we have a blood-brain barrier
that allows for that protein to come
across it and so you know having
something like when we look at
creatinine for urine about the clearance
Factor would be extremely essential to
understand that it's not that we're not
seeing it
it's just that it's not there yet so how
can we understand the timing
um and also you know the Confluence of
this image this um barrier that we're
seeing
um both in the blood-brain barrier as
well as lymphatic function
um also understanding of how proteins
are related to the origin
um many proteins I think that we
identify are great
um if we want a diagnostic biomarker
because they allow us to understand that
something's going on we need to focus on
that
but they're not necessarily related to
pathology
um because there's so many translations
of that protein that when we see
something it doesn't mean that if we
intervene based on that protein that
we're gonna have really an impact and so
our lab specifically has really been
related to understanding multiple time
points and then also you know canonical
Pathways and
um and have proteins to really
understand it's not just this one
Protein that's up or down regulated but
it's a protein that seems to be
influencing a number of Pathways that we
think are related to this and um that's
not always easy and um what we want to
do is within the same individual see
that same protein or that Network
changing over time and relating to
something that we can see in neural
Imaging
um and if not that at least within
patients reporting of symptoms or
objective things like neuropsychological
functioning
um also I'm going to show a little bit
of data about just
I think one of the things
um this is kind of paradigm shift that
it's happening within TBI is that
we used to think about TBI as kind of
like a broken bone
and so we can see it we can measure it
and then we can cure it
um but within TBI it's very different
because many of these injuries that we
think about TBI or concussion are
related to traumatic events
um like intimate partner violence child
abuse and other things like Community
violence and so we really need to
reconceptualize that to think about this
as not just a specific injury to an
organ or a bone but also to a whole
stressful response because this response
if somebody comes into an emergency room
and has this it also means that maybe
they're going to lose insurance because
of employment and so there's a lot of
things that can make recovery difficult
and it's not just neuro-analytical
um or biomarker based but it's really
integration of the psychosocial factors
that we know are so important
um and so it's really thinking about
you know it's not just the injury
mechanism the injury that we can see in
the biomarker we can see reflected in
the blood but it's overall the
environment that the individual is
living in
um including social and environmental
factors that really relate to this
individual variability that we see in
recovery from brain injuries
and so to show a little bit about this
um so this is just looking at the Time
Force and individuals have had a mild
brain injury and so you can see these
biomarkers vary greatly over time
and so this is one of the few studies
that looks at more long-term recovery
looking at these you know fourplex
proteins g-fap use casual one NFL and
Tau and we can see that again it's not
just the biomarker but it's the mile
marker combined with time that's the
most important factor and really
predicting these overall recovery
trajectories
[Music]
um one of the other things that we've
been able to look at more closely
especially in our concussion group is
um the impact of exercise so it used to
be that when individual had a concussion
they would just go into a dark room no
video games no sound no anything we
found that overall clinically that
wasn't therapeutic and so people go back
to exercise and things like that and so
when we're looking at biomarkers there
definitely is an impact of exercise just
itself and so in this study
um there are individuals who are
Collegiate athletes but they were not
engaged in their Collegiate sport so it
was off season and they did an aerobic
exercise like running with the trainer
push-ups sit-ups things like that and so
we can see differences based on these
biomarkers that we think are really
brain specific but actually are not
necessarily because they do have the
impact of exercise itself and so you see
you know overall some increases as well
as decreases Within These proteins and
so you know coming back within the NCAA
public and Care Consortium we we do we
we are able to look at the impact of
exercise
and also you know take it out of the
impact of self-compassive hits
um and so that's one of those things
that we just really need to look at
because we know from a lot of clinical
studies the exercise itself is
protective and facilitates recovery and
so we want to be able to use that but if
we're using exercises and intervention
then we also have to think about it as
changing these biomarkers that we think
about as monitoring biomarkers or
prognostic at least
um and so it's just really again looking
at individuals over time and
understanding the impact of these
overall
um you know activity related individual
variability things that um really
understand impact recovery over time
just give one more slide um on
individual variability it's really
um a lot of our Studies have looked up
gender or sex
um and it's kind of an Avenue into
looking at more sophisticated ways to
look at individual variability but we do
find that overall there are a lot of
impacts of this
um both ensure directory of Tau which
relates to recovery as well as these
other biomarkers and so going in and
seeing you know is it gender itself
which has a whole lot of characteristics
which are much more specific than sex
um or are there things that make some
individuals more likely to not recover
so how can we kind of take it out of
this box of yes versus no whenever we go
in somewhere for a medical appointment
or file our taxes or things like that to
understand the nature of it and what
characteristics matter most and so we
see that there's a signal there for sure
but what's the nature of that signal and
how can we understand the components of
that signal that matter most and so
that's a lot of the work that we're are
doing within my lab and so this is just
a conceptual model of kind of how we
think about
looking at this and so it's no longer
just that somebody has an injury and
then they have an outcome but there's a
lot of components that are pre-existing
when an individual comes into an
emergency room or is on a sports field
or has an injury when they're deployed
and so all of these pre-existing factors
can disregulate many of the the
functions that we think within the brain
as well as systemically that relate to
recovery including neurological changes
which can make individuals more likely
to have neurodegenerative processes as
well as the regulation of immune
function and so we think about this kind
of on a lifetime trajectory is that it's
not just one injury but many individuals
that have one TBI are much more likely
to have another based on their factors
um and so we want to really understand
the impact of this lasting symptoms and
how we can intervene to back really
modulate those to promote recovery
because overall in any type of study we
do we see you know tbis are related to
health morbidity Health mortality
employment
um just about any type of outcome you
can think about being negative tbis are
associated with that but it's not just
TBI itself but it's the way that the
individual interacts with it and so how
can we understand those factors in a
more comprehensive way to design
interventions that are going to be more
meaningful for those individuals to
really make an impact and so that's
really the function of our lab and with
that I'll take questions and thoughts
and I'd be really happy to get any
anything that would be important um to
add to the work that we're doing and um
I'll show you also a plug that
everything we do has trainees related to
it so if there's anybody who's looking
for training opportunities please let me
know
um we're always happy to do it remotely
as well as in person and thank you so
much for your time and attention
thank you so much Dr Gill for your
informative presentation I'm joining us
today for the live q a portion of this
broadcast is Dr Dion Denmark senior
director of translational medicine and
clinical development at somalogic we
will now start the live q a portion if
you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
now let's get started our first question
here
is have you compared the quantification
results obtained by Elisa and by Soma
scan are they correlated
yes so we have done that specifically
um so EPB 41 has been something that's
been elusive to us because
um unfortunately the antibodies are not
well established for that one so that
was the one that was really predictive
of diagnosis
um so that has been limited we're still
doing a lot of work related to that
um and we're trying to find you know
different ways to do that
um but what we have been able to do with
alpha nuclean is to do the same thing
and to use the quantaries platform to
validate our findings I didn't show them
here because we're still running it and
analyzing it but we do see that the
elevations related to the signal we see
within some of scan relate to um this
other you know antibody-based approach
um so that makes us highly confident in
what we're doing and that
um and I didn't present a lot of this
but Alpha snuklian
um it provides a lot of diagnostic
accuracy but it's much more important
prognostic and um so we're doing
um a lot of studies using that looking
within the care Consortium and as well
as other studies that work we have
ongoing so overall we found that it does
align
um our limitation has been if there's
not an established Elisa we have to do a
Homebrew on one of our methods and so
that's just been one of the things that
we've seen
um be difficult if there's not an
antibody that we can use to develop
those humbers
production is
so many of your patients have negative
side effects from the good gadolinium
and how many patients does they use the
battlelinium exacerbate the mtbi
symptoms
um so we have looked at this a little
bit because I know there's some
controversy with gadolinium
um again that's why we need a biomarker
that approximates that meningitial
injury
um we have not seen any significant
impairments So within the study most of
the individuals so we we get them
acutely we look at them and then we
follow them at five to seven days and
then there's a cohort that we also
follow at NIH for up to a year
um we have not seen any negative side
effects that are treated to gabolinium
that we can see
um but again that's a little bit flawed
because
um anytime you have a prospective study
in people with mild injuries you more
likely see those individuals who have
who are symptomatic coming back those
individuals who are healthy and just
kind of want to go on with their life
don't come back as often
um but from what we can see we don't
really see too much of an impact it's
not something that we're substantially
worried about but again that's the
reason we want to have a biomarker to
approximate it
thank you another question here how do
these findings compare to any of the
known or previously seen biology for
concussion or TBI
um so our findings with somalogic and
that really mild cohort
um we got an area under the curve
meaning that we were able to approximate
it with 100 accuracy
um using those two biomarkers
um that compares with what we did with
g-fap and UCR till one primarily
um we did use some mixed modeling
including Tau as well as NFL but it
really was g-fap and UCS were one that
drove that but the biggest accuracy we
could get was up to 0.83 in our area
depth curve so it definitely improved it
overall
okay next question here what were the
most exciting and or surprising findings
or insights from applying an unbiased
proteomic approach here versus pursuing
hypothesis-driven biomarkers
um so I'll just say um I've been very
privileged so my experience was at NIH
in the animail program and so
um I was not focused on grant writing
where you have to have a specific
pathology or biomarker set that you're
looking at and so my Approach is
probably different than a lot of
scientists who address this because I've
not been forced to say these five
biomarkers and this is the budget I need
to look at them
um any time we do anything in our lab
we'll look at we run fourplex data on
every sample and that does give us some
information
um but for example
um one of the studies we did with blast
so we did
um individuals who had a blast exposure
that was something you would call a
moderate blast exposure we actually saw
reductions in the same proteins that we
see in Priestess in so that means that
there's a different pathology going on
and so by using this type of Technology
we go and say like okay we're looking at
the wrong things
um and so how can we get this you know
to really understand the pathology of
that and so by using this we're able to
identify different protein Pathways and
then do some pre-clinical models that
were much more informative to understand
um because the issue especially with TBI
in military personnel and Veterans is
that blast exposure almost always
co-occurs with a brain injury and so
there's a blast that results in a blood
Force injury because the individual is
thrust into you know some type of
contact with something else and that
results in a brain injury and so you're
looking at two different injury
mechanisms
um which is much more difficult
difficult to understand because the
pathologies are different and the
mechanisms that we understand don't
necessarily overlap and so it's stuff
like this that allows us to go ahead and
say like we don't really know because
you know blast injury has been pretty
new in the last decade
um and so there's not established
biomarkers related to that and so we can
go and say like we can look at 7 000
proteins and understand it much better
than sitting around a table and saying
like let's test these five proteins in
these and then by the time we do that
then the sample is depleted and so it
really gives us an opportunity to go in
and say
you know it's okay if we don't know
what's going on but we can use this to
do it better
um and really inform the pathways and
the pathology that we're looking at so
it opens up a lot of Windows that
um we don't normally have and we do the
same thing as when we look at genomics
so we don't look at you know five
different genes we're looking across the
genome both in DNA and RNA as well as
micro RNA so anytime I have an
opportunity
to look at more candidates than people
think are reasonable I do it because
that just leads signs in a different way
and I think
our lab is data driven
um not hypothesis driven and so I always
say consistently I'm wrong every time I
say something's going to happen I'm
consistently wrong because the proteins
we look at don't necessarily correlate
to the outcomes we're looking at and so
if we don't get that Target we have the
ability to go in and so by going to
Hopkins
um the reason I did is that I have a
foundation that I can use and so I'm not
completely Grant driven and so I can use
these really great Technologies to say
let's build something new
um so you can find a protein and then
develop a panel to measure it and then
validate it and that just
it opens up so many more opportunities
than than what people do and I think
science has stagnated a lot by the
hypothesis-driven approach because
you can look at as much literature and
pre-clinical stuff but all the models
are different and it just doesn't lead
to new avenues and so I've been really
excited to be able to use this type of
thing to say like okay we didn't think
about EPB 41 being anything related we
never would but there it is and it's
really accurate and it's something that
we can use moving forward so
yeah it's a long one answered the
question this means that um anytime I
can use data to guide what we're doing
as opposed to going back to literature
we're going to do it
um because it just allows us to go in
directions that we wouldn't have think
thought of and and think like okay this
this just gives us a new window to think
about options of how we can intervene
thank you we have some great questions
coming in
um someone is asking have you done
replicates and is there some variability
between them
um so I would say between Soma logic
um I believe we have
um I'm not the best person so I know a
little bit about a lot of things but not
a lot about everything and so I know
that we have done some replicates
um especially when we're testing out the
technology so I'll say
um when we started using Sumo logic they
were at NIH and they were literally like
a floor above us
um and so we're like this is amazing
because it allows us to look at clinical
translational proteins and really
transform what we're doing
um so my um yeah the person who was
working my lab is kind of like the labs
I just did a lot of work on this before
we went into this and so the quality
controls and all of that was amazing
um and so I yeah I I haven't done it
recently but I felt very confident in
going into the technology
okay next question here what are the
challenges you have in tracking patient
medical or social history over time to
provide context for interpreting
biomarker results over time
well I think that could be a whole book
um yeah so patients are only as reliable
as the the information they want to
provide right so I always say like
anybody who we think is a healthy
control talk to them long enough and
they're not
um and so everybody's different and
different at every time point and so a
lot of our longitudinal studies are
tracking that so I talked a little bit
about NCAA
um so we're tracking those individuals
as they go into kind of their adult life
span and you know the concussion impact
um we also have a study in veterans
called limbic and
um we're looking overall about the
impact specifically of multiple tbis as
well as post-traumatic stress disorder
um and how that relates to compromises
and health and well-being
um but my thought is always that you
know everybody's resilient
um it just depends on when you see them
and when you have an opportunity to
intervene
um but those are going to be things that
I think are the challenges for our lab
in the next 10 years how do we measure
this the best
um one of the things I didn't talk about
today is we've developed sweat patches
that are highly related to the
biomarkers that we see in blood but
allows to collect them
um in a way where the person's in their
home environment and then they can
actually mail it back to our lab and
then we put on our same platforms
including Sumo logic and so
um that gives us again another window to
really understand
you know how somebody feels like at home
if they're caregiving if they've had a
brain injury if they have depression
um what are the biomarkers that relate
to compromise as well as health and
well-being and how can we use that to
really inform monitoring
um when to bring them in and when to
intervene but that's a really
it's complex
um you know and the more we study about
epigenetics too it's not just I mean
like when my kids were born I'm like
it's a healthy Soul you know anything
that happened to me before is not
inherited but now the more we're
learning it's not that way and so
there's transgenerational
um you know information about violence
and exposure and nutrition
um and so my ideas always comes back to
biomarkers can we use the biomarker to
approximate you know a resiliency Factor
versus a vulnerability Factor because we
can't ask all the questions that we need
to about somebody especially in the
acute trauma situation it's not
appropriate to talk about you know
additional traumas that they've had
before child abuse tbis things like that
what if you're going to buy a marker
that says you know this person has
vulnerability we don't need to know the
nature of the vulnerability just that we
need to intervene and so this is you
know an area that we're very very
focused on and happy to report hopefully
in 10 years we'll make progress I think
it's going to take that long to really
understand all these complex factors but
I think that's where science is and
where we'll make the biggest impact for
sure
thank you Dr Gayla we have time for a
few more questions
um another question here is how did
proteomics in particular Advance on
previous approaches for clinical
assessment and understanding
psychological consequences of concussion
so it's huge so
um
proteomics
um you know we do a lot of different
studies in our lab so our lab is not
just proteomic focused but reporting
advice is what you're going to use at
the bedside is what we can measure
um and it's what will really change
clinical practice and so for example if
we get somebody coming in with a TBI so
some tbis have
um you know a psychosocial focus with
them so it can be assault related
um traumatic events things like that and
so a lot of our work is focused not just
on neurological compromise but
psychological compromise and one of the
things we see consistently across our
studies if if somebody develops
post-traumatic stress especially if that
also is co-morbered with depression
that's where we see the biggest impact
on their health and well-being and so
that's likely going to be different
Pathways that relate to that as opposed
to say headache or light sensitivity
um and so it's those four clusters of
post-concussive syndrome that we're
trying to understand and it's really
through bigger studies and one of the
things like you know starting in this
um there are small studies and now we're
at the point where we have consortiums
and so we can look at things that are
subtle injuries that relate to these
long-term consequences and be much more
um specific in it and so we're looking
at how these different biomarkers map
onto different outcomes so what's a
predictor of PTSD versus a headache
what's a predictor of depression or
sleep disturbance how do they overlap
and then more importantly how can we
intervene so that way those individuals
most at risk we can mitigate those risk
factors
um so I don't have an answer
specifically but it's definitely an area
where we're focused on
um and hopefully through our consortiums
where we have these thousands of people
we can do that work it's just been
recently available to us to be able to
do that but I think that that is coming
on and I think you know just really
lends it over to personalized based
medicine is where we need to be with
tbis and concussion
um because every has different risk
factors based on previous history as
well as the injury mechanism as well as
the pathology specifically of the damage
to the brain and so how can we put that
together and say let's do this and we
think that this is the most optimal
because we really only have that small
window of being able to intervene where
we're going to have the opportunity to
reduce the impact of brain injury and
changes overall that really shape the
onset of those symptoms as well as it
developing in a more chronic nature
thank you so much and thank you again Dr
Gill for your time today and your
important research we'd also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor
somalogic for underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions any questions we do not have
time for today and those submitting
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by this speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration this webcast can be
viewed on demand and lab Roots will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with any one of your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye
thanks